los colores favoritos de tomás son azul
y verde tiene una camisa azul una camisa
verde un sombrero azul una bufanda verde
un pantalón azul y un pantalón verde
tomas selecciona una de esas prendas
aleatoriamente sea el evento de que
seleccione una prenda azul y se ave el
evento de que seleccione una camisa cuál
de las siguientes expresiones es
verdadera y antes de que le damos todas
estas expresiones lo que voy a hacer es
calcular estas probabilidades que vamos
a manejar aquí probabilidad del evento a
probabilidad del evento b probabilidad
de verdad oa probabilidad de adobe
probabilidad de a&b y lo vamos a hacer
antes de revisar todo lo que dice aquí
pensemos en la probabilidad de a
la probabilidad de ar es la probabilidad
de que seleccione una prenda azul así
que cuántos resultados igualmente
probables tenemos aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6
resultados igualmente probables 6
resultados igualmente probables y
cuántos de estos resultados podrían ser
prendas azules aquí hay una dos y tres
de estos resultados igualmente probables
podrían ser prendas azules así que
tenemos tres sextos o un medio de
probabilidad de seleccionar una prenda
azul ahora vamos a ver la probabilidad
de ve la probabilidad de ver voy a usar
otro color y ve es el evento de que
seleccione una camisa y una vez más hay
seis prendas igualmente probable es que
tomás podría seleccionar y tenemos que
ver cuáles de estas son camisas aquí hay
una
2 y parece que solamente hay dos camisas
dos de seis podrían ser camisas o
podemos decir que la probabilidad de que
seleccione una camisa es igual a un
tercio la probabilidad de be es igual a
un tercio
ahora vamos a calcular la probabilidad
de ha dado b
cuál es la probabilidad de han dado b
cuál es la probabilidad de a cuando vea
sucedido la probabilidad de adobe es que
seleccione una prenda azul dado que ha
seleccionado una camisa y esto nos
restringe los resultados a estos dos que
tenemos aquí y la probabilidad de que
sea una prenda azul es uno de estos dos
resultados igualmente probables así que
la probabilidad de adobe es igual a un
medio un medio es la probabilidad de que
seleccione una prenda azul si ha
seleccionado una camisa y esto es porque
sólo hay una camisa azul y una camisa
verde
ahora vamos a ver la probabilidad de ver
la probabilidad de ver dando a
asumiendo que se ha seleccionado una
prenda azul cuál es la probabilidad de
que sea una camisa así que tenemos aquí
una prenda azul aquí hay otra y aquí hay
otra y cuál es la probabilidad de que
además sea una camisa bueno tenemos 123
resultados igualmente probables de
seleccionar una prenda azul y solo uno
de esos es una camisa así que la
probabilidad de verdad es un tercio y
finalmente vamos a pensar en la
probabilidad de a&b así que la
probabilidad de a&b
ahí ve
es la probabilidad de seleccionar una
prenda azul y camisa o sea una camisa
azul y solo hay un resultado dentro de
los seis resultados igualmente probables
así que aquí ponemos la probabilidad que
es uno sobre seis y un sexto bueno ahora
que ya obtuvimos estos resultados vamos
a revisar las preguntas la probabilidad
de ha dado b es igual a la probabilidad
de a parece que si es igual la
probabilidad de ha dado b es un medio y
es lo mismo que la probabilidad de a la
probabilidad de que tomás seleccione una
prenda azul dado que él ha escogido una
camisa es igual a la probabilidad de que
tomadas seleccione una prenda azul si es
lo que acabamos de ver aquí ya revisamos
que los valores en la anotación
matemática son iguales así que
definitivamente esta expresión es
verdadera
la probabilidad de verdad es igual a la
probabilidad de b la probabilidad de
haber dado a es un tercio y la
probabilidad de b es un tercio la
probabilidad de que tomás seleccione una
camisa dado que él ha seleccionado una
prenda azul es igual a la probabilidad
de que tomás seleccione una camisa si es
correcto esta también es verdadera
hay veces son eventos independientes
bueno dos eventos son independientes lo
voy a escribir de este lado en notación
matemática los eventos son
independientes y la probabilidad de
adarve es igual a la probabilidad de a
entonces podemos decir que los eventos
son independientes porque la
probabilidad de a es igual a la
probabilidad de a sin importar si el
evento ve sucede o no así podemos
comprobar que dos eventos son
independientes también lo podemos ver
con la probabilidad de b dado a si es
igual a la probabilidad de b es el mismo
argumento los eventos son independientes
o si vemos la probabilidad de ave es
igual a la probabilidad de a por la
probabilidad de b esto también nos
indica que los eventos son
independientes y vemos que esto es
cierto y que la probabilidad de a&b es
un sexto y la probabilidad de a por la
probabilidad de b es un medio por un
tercio que es igual a un sexto bueno
todo esto claramente cierto así que
podemos decir que los eventos a yves son
independientes la probabilidad de a es
independiente de lo que pase con be y la
probabilidad de be es independiente de
lo que pase con a vamos al siguiente los
resultados de los eventos a ibex son
dependientes uno del otro
esto es exactamente lo opuesto de ser
independientes y ya vimos que estos
eventos son independientes así que esta
expresión no es verdadera la
probabilidad de a&b es igual a la
probabilidad de a por la probabilidad de
b ya vimos que esto es verdadero un
sexto es igual a un medio por un tercio
la probabilidad de que tomás seleccione
una prenda azul que sea camisa es igual
a la probabilidad de que tomás
seleccione una prenda azul multiplicada
por la probabilidad de que seleccione
una camisa y si esto es verdadero
casi todas las expresiones son
verdaderas con excepción de esta que
dice que los resultados de los eventos a
y b son dependientes uno del otro